جبال فرونجا ، سلسلة من البراكين في شرق إفريقيا
تمتد على الحدود بين رواندا
أوغندا
وجمهورية الكونغو الديمقراطية ،
إنها واحدة فقط من مكانين في العالم
لمشاهدة الغوريلا الجبلية في البرية
، كانت عالمة الرئيسيات الشهيرة ديان
فوس هي
التي جعلت هذه الغوريلا مشهورة.  عاش
وعمل بينهم
ما يقرب من 20 عامًا ،
فأنت تأخذ أوراقًا صغيرة ، وتأخذ هذه الأوراق ،
تعال إلى هنا ،
دليل الرحلات الخاص بي هو فرانسواز
بيجيريمانا ،
الذي كان يعمل مع fosse ذات مرة ، وهو الآن
أسطورة في حد ذاته ،
يا إلهي ، يا إلهي ،
هل تشعر أن لديك  التواصل
مع الغوريلا
نعم ، لأنني أشعر في قلبي أنني
أحبهم كثيرًا
تمامًا مثل أطفالي
[موسيقى]
أنا متحمس حقًا
لمواجهة أبناء عمومتنا وجهاً لوجه
إذا لم تكن في بيئتهم
حديقة حيوانات أو ملاهي  بارك أو
أي شيء من هذا القبيل ،
لكن في الغابة ،
هناك قرصنة ،
أحاول مواكبة هذا رائع ،
هذه غابة حقيقية
سميكة مع نبات القراص يلدغ ساقي من
خلال سروالي ، أنا أرتدي  حلقة البوابات
لمنع النمل من التسلق على ساقي
وفجأة تمامًا مثلما كنا نتحدث معهم ،
يتحدث فرانكواز بلغتهم
لإبقائهم هادئين ، إنه أمر
سريالي أنهم معتادون على البشر
المعتادين
ولكن لا تخلطوا أن هذه الغوريلا لم يتم
ترويضها تعال  وهذا يؤدي إلى
لحظات تتسارع فيها دقات القلب ،
وهذا بالطبع هو سبب مجيئي إلى هنا ،
وهذا أمر رائع حقًا
ولكن لرؤيتهم قريبة ، ثم
يستيقظون ويمشيون أمامك ، فأنا حزين جدًا
لأننا نتشارك  إلى 98
من علم الوراثة مع هذه الوحوش الرائعة
وجوههم مثل هذا التعبير
[الموسيقى]
إنه لأمر ساحق أن هناك الكثير من
الغوريلا التي تنتشر في جميع
الغوريلا كان يجب أن
تنقرض الآن
بفضل الحفظ طويل الأمد
لأعدادهم تتزايد
الآن بأكثر من ألف  في البرية
بالكاد بعيدًا عن الغابة ، انظر ، انظر
[ضحك]
لكن مستقبلهم أفضل
بكثير مما
كان جيدًا ، الإجابة الجيدة هي أنك تعلم أن
الوقت قد حان دعنا نقول لك
وداعًا  وداعا للغوريلا ، من المثير
للإعجاب أن ترى هذا
ليس فقط بسبب صعوبة
الرحلات هنا
ثم البحث عن الغوريلا
ولكن المفاجأة في الوصول إليها
وهم في
كل مكان وهم يعرفون أنك هناك
ولكنهم لا يفعلون ذلك حقًا  الرعاية
وبعد ذلك ، وبسرعة ، ذهبوا
رائعين تمامًا ، قالت ديان فوسي إن الغوريلا لديها إيثار تقريبًا ،
وهناك القليل جدًا مني ،
أشعر بأنني محظوظ جدًا
لرؤيتها وإدراك مدى كونها
رمزًا مثاليًا لهذا البلد حيث
يحاول الجميع ذلك  اسحب في نفس
الاتجاه